now our next guest Peter mandelson was
alongside Tony Blair and Gordon Brown
one of the architects of new labor which
was of course one of the most
electorally successful eraser of well
any part of his party in particular he
famous the one said he was intensely
relaxed about people getting Filthy Rich
although he did sort of walk it back
slightly years later well I'm very uh
looking forward to speaking to him to
try and find out about how he thinks
labor should react to Friday's tax cuts
and does he think costama is ready to be
prime minister good to have you on the
program this morning at Mr mandelson
um
I'm afraid you didn't uh complete my
quote
uh I talked about it's fine for people
to become rich as long as they pay their
taxes a rather important qualification
which you left out
absolutely I completely uh take your
point on that um are you relaxed about
the bankers bonus cat then just quickly
before we start the rest of the
interview
I don't really have strong views on the
bankers bonus cap either way frankly I
don't think it's a priority uh for us in
getting the economy growing again I mean
what I feel about the Chancellor's
package on Friday
is that it will take some time to see uh
how Reckless a gamble it may well turn
out to be through higher inflation
higher higher borrowing costs for
companies higher interest rates for
mortgage holders
um so let's see how this uh pans out but
I do believe that what Labor's got to do
is not concentrate on all the noise
surrounding uh what is trusted and
quasi-quarten are doing they've got to
concentrate on their own agenda setting
out their own plan for growth
and I'm very pleased that they've
started to do that at the at the
conference in Liverpool today
growth because
he made a speech saying that labor
should focus on raising the UK's
long-term growth rate it feels since she
made that speech that Liz truss has done
everything she can to try and occupy
that space do you think I guess Labor's
been a bit slow at the blocks on this
I don't think this trust is doing that I
think she is certainly taking the
country off in a radical Direction but I
don't think it's the right direction
because at the same time as these
measures that we heard from heard about
on Friday
the government is also closing down all
the Machinery relating to the
development and exploitation of
Britain's brilliant Science and
Technology based in this country you
know she's closed down the cabinet
committee the National Machinery for
bringing government and business
together to exploit uh the new
technologies she's closed down the
office of Science and Technology
strategy in the cabinet office this is
the wrong thing to do what we've got to
do is as Ed miliband was saying before
is invest very heavily and primarily
through private sector investment in the
technology-based new Industries and
markets and employment that are emerging
now in our economy and that private
investment depends on economic stability
regulatory certainty
cheap borrowing costs but also a very
strong partnership between government
and business and I'm glad that the
shadow business secretary Johnny
Reynolds is publishing a document
tomorrow precisely on that subject how
Government Can Work hand in hand with
the private sector to bring about that
much needed investment in the whole
Spate of technology-based new industries
that are emerging at this heart of which
is the green energy transition
you're talking about the talking about
the green energy transition and you've
decided that you know Labor's commitment
to spending 28 billion pounds for 10
years on climate change and you were
talking about in this speech saying just
announcing a massive spend and a big
policy goal does not in itself deliver
economic growth do you still have those
concerns or do you think you're getting
a bit more meat on the bone now oh we're
getting much more meat on the bone I
mean look
the whole point is this Sophie if I can
just make it very simply and clearly
government and business public
investment and private investment
together
needs to invest in these new
technology-based Industries and markets
that are emerging not just from the
green transition but the whole diffusion
of digital technology and the emerging
critical Technologies like artificial
intelligence and the use of of data
across the economy in society but here's
the point we've got to translate those
great transitions that are taking place
into the creation of UK industry
uk-based Supply chains and UK based
employment rather than seeing that
massive expenditure leaking out of our
economy and going off to benefit our
neighboring economies and I'm very
pleased that
the plans that are going to be set out
this week both by Rachel Reeves Ed
miliband and Johnny Reynolds again to
set out that industrial policy which
needs to support this very large-scale
uh public and private investment
now you of course are parts of the most
successful
sixth team ever
weapons of election success the famous
of course 1997 Landslide under Tony
Blair and you've been pretty critical of
where Labor's been since you said that
labor needs a complete break from the
last 10 years of failure under Ed
miliband and Jeremy corbyn also
describing milliban this was in 2021 as
a flop and a complete failure has that
complete break happened
I don't remember describing Ed Miller
Band in that way but I'm sure your
researchers will be able to furnish you
uh with the facts look here's the point
about Friday and it offers both an
opportunity and a challenge for labor
the opportunity is that in taking
tearing off in the direction they've
chosen the conservatives are forfeiting
their reputation for sound money and
fiscal discipline that's been a very
hard one electoral weapon that they've
created and deployed since Mrs
Thatcher's uh time and they've thrown
that away in the measures they announced
on Friday but here's the challenge for
labor
in in responding to what Liz truss is
doing is taking the conservative party
uh it back into its own sort of
ideological right-wing comfort zone as
we saw them doing uh on Friday Labor's
response should not be to retreat into
its own uh Comfort uh zone of tax and
spend and big state and the policies
that we associate with Jeremy corbyn you
know the public have got to know and
they've got to be reminded every day
from here to Bolding day that Jeremy
corbyn and his supporters and all they
stood for are behind us and that it's
now completely safe to vote for labor
again that we've got sensible middle
Crown practical affordable policies
which are going to bring about that
economic transformation and that
structural change in our economy that we
need in order to sustain economic growth
in the long term
do you think labor would now win the
next election
I I do actually believe that what we are
seeing emerging in the country is a sort
of shift in public opinion
um I think we are seeing a potential uh
sea change in attitudes in the public
about what the public wants and what the
public won't put up with but but here's
the point Liz trusts in effect and the
conservatives in their effect
are taking their own policy Direction
off the center ground the middle ground
or British politics now that creates an
opportunity for labor to occupy that uh
Center ground the that's where the
swathe of Voters exist in the country
who are going to determine the outcome
of the next election and their focused
both on economic competence
unfairness in social justice those are
two sides of the coin the policy coin
the political coin that the broad mass
of Voters right across the center ground
are British politics are focused on
that's what they want to vote for and
that's what labor needs to offer
thank you we are out of time but just
quickly um do you speak much to kirst
armor offer him any advice
I I do speak to him from uh time to time
yes and members of his team but I don't
do for him and for them what I did for
uh Tony Blair and Gordon Brown and
before them uh Neil kinnick but whenever
they want any help you know my door my
phone's uh there for them to to call but
you know they they've chosen their
course they want to do their own thing I
perfectly well understand that and
actually I strongly support the course
uh they're taking and I support Kia
stalma because I think he's a
hard-working public spirited uh
patriotic uh leader for this country uh
the Prime Minister that I think
overwhelmingly now the part the public
are moving towards and deciding that
they want to see in number 10.
okay thank you very much uh indeed
mandelson